ابدأ بالأخبار العاجلة من المغرب،
حيث ارتفع عدد القتلى بسبب
زلزال قوي ومدمر
بشكل كبير، ويقول التلفزيون الحكومي إن أكثر من 600
شخص قتلوا وأصيب أكثر من 300
آخرين، نقلاً عن
وزارة الداخلية، وتقول هيئة المسح الجيولوجي الأمريكية إن
الزلزال بقوة 6.8 درجة.  كانت
أقوى عمليات الإنقاذ في المنطقة منذ أكثر من 120
عامًا، وتجري عمليات الإنقاذ في
البلاد في هذه الساعة.
وأسقطت الهزات الأرضية المباني في جميع أنحاء المنطقة. ويقول
المسؤولون إن هناك حاجة ملحة
للتبرع بالدم للضحايا
وإلقاء نظرة على هذا الفيديو.  هذا
يوضح اللحظة التي هز فيها الزلزال
مسجدًا في مراكش في وقت متأخر من ليلة الجمعة،
إنه أمر لا يصدق وما يبدو أنه
غبار يتصاعد من المبنى بينما كان الناس
يفرون بحثًا عن الأمان في الشوارع،
ينضم إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة آه للأسف
أم لاري، يبدو أن عدد القتلى قد
انخفض  ولكن اليوم قد انبثق هناك، هل
يمكنك أن تخبرنا المزيد عن
جهود الإنقاذ وما تقوله السلطات
حول المكان الذي وقع فيه هذا الزلزال.
تقول الحكومة المغربية إنها
نشرت جميع الموارد المتاحة لها
للاستجابة لهذا الزلزال، وهي
أقوى ما تمتلكه البلاد  شوهد
منذ عام 1900
وكان مركز الزلزال في منطقة النسر في
جبال الأطلس المرتفعة،
جنوب
الوجهة السياحية التاريخية الشهيرة في مراكش، وكان التأثير
محسوسًا على مسافة أبعد بكثير من المكان الذي
حدث فيه هذا، وكان عمق هذا الزلزال
ضحلًا نسبيًا فقط  حوالي 11.5 ميلًا تحت
سطح الأرض، لكن حتى
زلزالًا ضحلًا مثل هذا لا يزال بإمكانه إحداث
أضرار جسيمة، ولهذا السبب
ترى هذا العدد من 632 قتيلًا مؤكدًا حتى الآن،
وأكثر من 300 جريح
تخشى السلطات أنه عند الانتهاء من الحساب الكامل،
يمكن أن تكون هذه الأرقام  أعلى بكثير
لأنهم بدأوا الآن في الانتقال إلى
هذه المناطق التي يصعب الوصول إليها في
المنطقة الجبلية، حيث تم إغلاق بعض الطرق،
وليس من السهل الوصول إليها،
وهناك احتمال أن يكون هذا قد حدث
حوالي الساعة 11 مساءً بالتوقيت المحلي، مما قد يكون بعض الأشخاص
محاصرين  في منازلهم أو
تحت هذه المباني التي
انهارت، وقع الضرر الغربي في
هذه المناطق الجبلية التي
يصعب الوصول إليها في كثير من الأحيان، فهي ذات كثافة
سكانية منخفضة للغاية، والناس ليسوا
قريبين جدًا من بعضهم البعض ولكنهم
سيحاولون التدقيق في كل ذلك  والوصول
إليهم وسيكون ذلك
مكثفًا حقًا، أريد أن أريكم هذه
اللقطات التليفزيونية الشقيقة المذهلة
للحظة التي ضرب فيها هذا الزلزال، ورؤية
كاميرون الناس بحثًا عن الأمان ثم
بدأ الحطام في التساقط
وهذا يفسر فقط تأثير هذا
الزلزال وليس  فقط في مركز الزلزال هذا
ولكن بعيدًا جدًا ولهذا السبب
رأيت الكثير من الناس نائمين في
الشوارع خائفين من أنهم إذا بقوا في
منازلهم فقد تنهار
عليهم منازلهم، ترى الناس يتم سحبهم بعيدًا
بكل أنواع ما في وسعهم حقًا
حاول إبعادهم إلى مكان آمن، حيث
قتل الكثير من الأشخاص، بعض مقاطع الفيديو هذه التي
تظهر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، مقاطع فيديو مروعة لجثث ملقاة
في الشوارع
تتحدث فقط عن مدى سوء ما
يحدث خاصة في الليل عندما يكون بعض
الناس نائمين على الأرجح، أريدك أن
تستمع  إلى هذا الرجل الذي
لم يكن في مركز الزلزال والذي كان
بعيدًا في الدار البيضاء ولكن حتى هناك كان هناك الكثير
من الخوف
اهتز المنزل بقوة
كان الجميع خائفين وصدمت ولم
أفهم ما كان يحدث واعتقدت أن
منزلي فقط هو الذي  كانت تتحرك
لأنها هشة وقديمة وسمعت
الناس يصرخون، خرج الجميع من
منازلهم، الشارع مليء بالناس
والنساء يصرخون، هذا ما
حدث حتى الآن لا يستطيع الناس العودة إلى
منازلهم لأنهم ما زالوا خائفين